[Music]
[Music]
it
we're trying to give
whatever we can
as there is a difficult thought if it
runs out of field the fuel is the woods
the houses everything around
can you describe how you're feeling
right now i know it's emotional and i'm
so sorry
when you see so much distraction
it doesn't help you by you trying to
work from inside i'm sorry
[Music]
angry i feel angry i lost i lost my home
i lost my house i lost my my
place my birthday place nothing will be
the same the next day
i am very angry most people here are
very angry
our villages are destroyed there is
nothing left
from our homes our properties nothing
nothing people need help
need help they lost their homes they
lost their jobs
they need help the government has huge
[Music]
responsibilities
[Music]
fire rescue teams here in the north of
athens are doing the best job they can
we've seen
one water tanker team as well as
firefighters
put out a bush fire and a house fire
just over in that direction but within
seconds of that fire being put out
this one has just erupted and become
much bigger and if you can see by the
train tracks
the fire is climbing up the hill just
behind us